okay it is time for hatred mail quick
reminder what are we talking about when
we talk about hatred mail brace
yourselves for the only information that
can successfully penetrate a tin foil
hats Patriot mail written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America
and because freedom
this makes hatred mail actually is is a
perfect segue into something I've been
meaning to discuss with you let's take a
listen to it David Pakman
[Music]
this new beta defeatist mentality you
developed is why Dems always lose always
great commentary from the beta males of
Pakman cute but meaningless we
congratulate soy boy Pakman on the
subscriber counts it is now higher than
his sperm count he shows that even a
beta male can be amazing I was thinking
how quickly these memes come in and out
of favor about a year ago this whole
beta male versus alpha male thing was
huge it was everywhere online now it
seems to only be satirical it's kind of
a joke soy boy sort of a similar thing
and by the way yes the subscriber count
is climbing my goal is for us to reach
eight hundred thousand YouTube
subscribers by my birthday on February
2nd so here's the math of it I looked at
the math this morning as of this
recording we are 11 days from my
birthday
now that's 11 days from the start of
February 2nd you know there's this full
24 hour period all the way up until
midnight on February 3rd but let's
ignore that for now
we're 11 days from the start of my
birthday as of right now we are 3511
subscribers away from 800,000 so in
order to get to 800,000 subscribers by
my birthday
we need to net gain 319 subscribers a
day that's not unreasonable because on a
good day like for example the first day
of the Trump impeachment trial when we
had a livestream
we had a bunch of videos that did well
we had a net gain of a thousand
subscribers now on a bad day for example
like on a weekend when things are slower
on YouTube sometimes we only gain a
hundred subscribers every once in a
while YouTube will close down inactive
accounts and when they do that we lose
subscribers as those accounts are purged
so it's doable it'll probably be a close
call so help us it's a way to send a
middle finger salute to the hey tree
it's youtube.com slash the david pakman
show hit subscribe 800,000 is the goal
by February 2nd